C'était sensas'.
Karen ?
C'est ton frère !
Alan !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Hé bien, nous devions nous voir.
Pour préparer notre week-end à St-Obispo.
Tiens, tiens Steven.
Ça fait plaisir de vous voir Monsieur Podcast.
Ça fait longtemps.
D'ailleurs j'ai croisé vos fils, Alan et Steven...
Toujours entrain de se chamailler ces deux-là.
Ils sont en tout cas en très bonne santé.
Ce qui n'est malheureusement pas...
Votre cas !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Rien, rien...
On discutait...
Ah oui ? Et vous discutiez de quoi ?
De... Des concerts !
Des concerts ?
Ah c'est vrai qu'il doit y avoir un tas de trucs marrants à dire sur les concerts.
Et qu'est-ce que vous disiez à ce sujet ?
Qu'est-ce qui m'a pris de dire ça ?
Si je ne trouve rien à dire sur les concerts, il va comprendre que nous n'étions pas du tout entrain de discuter !
Les nouvelles ne sont pas bonnes.
Monsieur Podcast...
En tant que proche incontesté de cette famille, je me dois de vous dire la vérité.
Oui, allô ?!
Qu'est-ce que vous dites ?!
Alors ?
Vous disiez quoi ?
Que... Il me disait que ce qui est marrant...
C'est qu'il n'y a que dans les salles de concert...
Qu'on reste une heure et demie debout à écouter de la musique.
Oui ! Tu t'imagines écouter du Michael dans ton salon...
Debout comme ça pendant une heure et demie ?
C'est ça que je disais.
J'ai déjà fait refaire ma cuisine il y a 6 mois, je n'ai pas le budget.
Et encore moins le temps pour ça !
Excusez-moi.
Comme je vous le disais...
l'heure est grave.
Concernant vos examens...
Ah oui !
Ça n'aurait pas de sens d'écouter de la musique comme ça pendant une heure et demie debout dans son salon.
On est d'accord.
J'étais entrain de m'imaginer le truc, en fait.
C'est pour ça que je parlais plus. Ah ok !
Si t'es comme ça, dans ton salon, comme ça pendant une heure et demie.
T'imagines le gars ? N'importe quoi.
Et vous avez dit quoi d'autre ?
Merde !
Le propriétaire de la voiture immatriculée 092LAJ est prié de déplacer son véhicule.
Merci !
C'est à vous ?
Où en étais-je ?
Ah oui !
Je vais vous dire les choses le plus simplement du monde.
Vous allez...
Mas qui cela peut-il bien être ?
Je vois pertinemment votre poing entrain de taper sur la table Docteur Miles.
Vous aimez trop faire des suspens vous les médecins.
On perd un temps fou à chaque fois !
Excusez-moi.
C'est bon, stop, ça suffit !
J'ai le droit de savoir ce que j'ai.
Monsieur Podcast, j'ai le regret de vous annoncer...
Que vous allez...
Tomber dans le coma.
Et bien, vous savez quoi Docteur Miles ?
Cette nouvelle me ravie.
Quoi ?
Faux !
Filou !
Je reconnais bien là Monsieur Podcast !
Blague à part...
Comment on fait pour le coma du coup ?
Parce qu'il se trouve que j'ai un planning chargé.
Réjouissez-vous Monsieur Podcast...
Je vous ai prévenu suffisamment à l'avance...
Pour que vous puissiez vous organiser.
Par exemple...
Décidez lequel de vos deux fils...
va reprendre l'entreprise familiale ?
Deux fils...
Suis-je bête ?
Je veux dire trois fils !
Mes trois fils ?!
Bah alors ?
Vous n'avez dit que ça ?
Je sais !
Non...
Je lui disais notamment que les premières parties des concerts...
C'est comme les préliminaires les garçons.
C'est pas pour ça qu'on a payé le ticket mais on est obligé de se les coltiner si on veut pouvoir voir...
Les Pink Floyd...
Bien joué Steven.
T'es le meilleur.
Et Dieu sait qu'il y en a qui adorent les premières parties.
N'est-ce pas Karen ?
Attends Steven ! Peux-tu répéter ce que tu viens de dire ?
Merde ! Quel con !
Tu ne respectes donc rien Steven.
Ce n'est pas du tout ce que tu crois Alan !
La blague que tu viens de faire sur les préliminaires...
C'est une blague de Friends !
Comment oses-tu faire une blague de Friends sans citer ta source ?!
C'est Chandler qui fait cette blague dans l'intro du 2ème épisode de la saison 1 !
Et tu le sais très bien !
Ne fais pas l'innocent !
Je ne le savais pas aussi à cheval sur le vol de blague !
Je ne savais pas qu'il connaissait aussi bien Friends.
Oui, vos trois fils.
Steven...
Alan...
Et Brandon !
Votre fils caché !
Mes trois fils...
Ah mon Dieu !
J'oublie toujours que j'ai un fils caché.
Ah ça, c'est con ça. C'est con, hein ?
Faut le noter, il y a une appli.
Il y a une appli où on peut noter tous les fils cachés qu'on a...
Parce que moi j'avais mis un post-it sur le frigo et ça a pas... Un post-it c'est con et...
Une appli, un rappel... Bah une notif' !
Une notif' ça marche toujours. Ouais ça marche toujours.
Un téléphone, on l'a toujours sur soi...
Bon ! Bon, bah voili, voilou. Sans rancune !
Bon coma, hein !
Je vous remercie !
Qui de Alan ou de Steven ou de...
Brandon...
reprendra l'entreprise familiale ?
Vous le saurez prochainement dans les Frères Podcast.
Peut-être pas dans l'épisode suivant mais accrochez-vous, on va pas tarder à le savoir.
Moi j'ai le nez pour ce genre de truc, en général.